I protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using Aura I get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so I
can fix the problem fast try Aura free
for two weeks using my link below
all right let's start in a way we
haven't started for a while which is by
talking about the coronavirus pandemic
you know I got a few emails from people
saying David if you want to be fair
you've got to call out Joe Biden for
something that he recently said Joe
Biden recently said the pandemic is over
that's not true and if you're going to
be fair you can't let that slide well I
call out anybody who says things that
aren't true and Joe Biden did on 60
Minutes say the pandemic is over and the
pandemic is not over and I will make
that case in a moment but maybe maybe
not in the way you would assume I would
make it so let's first listen to what
Joe Biden said Mr President first
Detroit Auto Show in three years yeah
is the pandemic over a pandemic is over
and we still have a problem with covet
we're still doing a lot of work on it uh
it's but the pandemic is over if you
notice no one's wearing masks everybody
seems to be in pretty good shape and so
I think it's changing and I think this
is a perfect example of it this is
pretty silly it really is now there's
two interpretations here when Joe Biden
says listen the pandemic is over as
evidenced by the auto show is back
there's no masks and everyone here seems
to be doing okay you know forget about
the millions that have died for a second
but this really isn't true now this
isn't about me I am not saying I need to
hold on to every guideline we ever had
no I mean I'm not wearing masks I'm out
in the world I'm doing things this is
not a question of of me my behavior is
basically back to normal but it's not
true that the pandemic is over when you
look at the sort of of numbers that we
have right now in the United States you
know an average of somewhere between 60
and 90 000 new cases a day would we add
a hundred cases a day at the start of
the pandemic it was a disaster we now
have 60 to 90 000 that we know of and
probably two or three times more from
people doing home tests or not getting
tested at all when you look at the death
numbers
we still have somewhere between you know
three and five hundred people dying
every single day from covid so here are
the things Joe Biden could have said
that would have been true
we've gotten accustomed to the current
level of death from covid and we
consider it normal and acceptable and a
fair exchange to going back to our
normal lives generally speaking that
would have been an accurate statement
from Joe Biden or we don't think we
really can reduce the number of deaths
from where they are right now so we're
not even really going to try
okay I mean that that would have been an
accurate statement
um I think it is true to say that
politically the pandemic rhetoric has
ended
um but there's no real way
mathematically to make the case that the
pandemic is over and to be clear I am
not coming at this from I'm trying to
get everybody back in their homes and
wearing masks and no large Gatherings or
anything I'm not advocating for any of
that I'm part of the group that has said
you know it seems like it's going to be
like this at least for a few more years
and at a certain point it's
understandable that for the most part
most people have gone completely back to
normal am I going to large sporting
events right now no I'm not but I was
already kind of starting not to before
the pandemic just because the crowds are
annoying and I hate sitting in traffic
and all of that stuff but
um to say the pandemic is over you can't
really back it up with any statistical
data and so what we have done and it's
okay to accept this it is I mean a
similar thing happened after the flu
pandemic of 1918.
the pandemic ends culturally and
socially in a way before there is any
medical end to the pandemic and because
covet is a little different and we see
without getting now into the medical
part of it between variants and all
these other things it's likely going to
be around for a while if not longer than
a while the medical end
may not come for a period of time it may
not ever come in a sense but the
political end the social and the
cultural end we expected would happen
sooner now what will things look like in
January who knows but that would be a
more fair assessment as of right now so
Joe Biden is just wrong I still agree
with student loan debt forgiveness
I still think the inflation reduction
Act is good I still think Joe Biden has
done a lot more good things than many
recent presidents but on this particular
thing he simply isn't correct let's
stick with covet a little bit
uh on Fox News
right after praising coveted vaccines
Greg Gutfeld very casually segues into
kovid was created by scientists just
without even any hesitation without any
even raising of an eyebrow Gutfeld says
that and of course we have no evidence
for that that's one of the early
conspiracy theories that surged about
covid take a look at this bizarre clip
on Fox News it's sick as people were so
I think that's that's the thing now we
can still have these conversations but
the president's largely right and anyone
in his team who doesn't believe it maybe
they should look for all the work okay
wrap it up Greg well I got to go with
Harold on this I think that if we sit we
cannot have it both ways we can't hail
operation warp speed and then laugh
about
the vaccines vaccines may not prevent
coven but they certainly reduce the
severity of it that's what it's there
for but the thing that drives me crazy
is that we still we have to accept that
more than likely it was man-made why why
why would we have to accept that and
when you think about it it's now the
third part of the cold and flu season I
don't think it's ever going to go away I
think you're going to have cold flu and
covid it's like our siblings in sickness
got a new little brother like cold okay
so he's reading that this is I guess
comedy gutfeld's a comedian so he's
reading some of this stuff off of his
notes which is fine but none of it's
funny and it's also not true so this has
been studied always remember
when a conspiracy theory has attached to
it Like A Parasite and they won't even
let us investigate
Bing that should set your alarms up is
that true is that true that we can't
even investigate the so-called lab leak
hypothesis has been investigated
extensively and there are two versions
of the lab leak hypothesis one the most
weaponized is covid was deliberately
created as a bio weapon and released to
kill people
that's one hypothesis the slightly less
cuckoo hypothesis is it was being
studied and it accidentally escaped the
lab because someone at the lab infected
themselves and then left and then it
spread from there those are the two kind
of layers now the view of scientists is
that both of those are very unlikely
right now the most likely scenario and
again in science we talk in terms of
probabilities the most likely scenario
is What's called the natural zoonotic
jump from animals to humans the entire
idea of lab leak
is based initially on
Wuhan markets is where we were told it
came from
and there's a virology lab in Wuhan so
it's very easy to claim it was from the
markets when it was really from the lab
because they're both physically in
proximity that's the bulk of why people
are talking about this now the truth is
there's lots of these types of labs in
many places
um and that should also kind of make us
question whether that makes sense now is
it possible that this was being studied
in that particular lab and someone was
accidentally infected and then they left
and then they started spreading it to
other people and that's how it entered
the human population it is of course
possible but we have been told no one at
that lab was sick at the time covid
emerged but could they be lying there
are claims that that's a lie well you
look at the clusters of early covid
cases and you see that there are links
to multiple markets in Wuhan around the
exact same time and so that supports the
idea that some animals Animal Traders
brought the virus in in animals to the
city brought those animals to a bunch of
the markets in Wuhan sold in many
markets and spread from there now you
know we could go further on this
at this point it's completely
irresponsible to say we have to admit
the most likely scenario is that this
was created by scientists that is not
the most likely scenario based on what
we know today if that changes I will be
the first to tell you
last thing sort of tangentially related
to covet a number of you sent to me an
extraordinarily disturbing video a
failed former president Donald Trump's
former National Security adviser Michael
Flynn a guy who was of course convicted
by uh after being indicted
um Michael Flynn
it's sort of like it come just comes out
you can't even control it it's like a
diarrhea of the mouth an incredible
conspiracy word salad involving DNA
altering coveted shots and Yuval Harari
the author wanting to turn people into
cyborgs with robotic components this is
really full-on and I want you to
remember
two things number one at one point this
was the top National Security official
in the country
and this is the stuff that he is now
saying and number two
um
they continue the the folks that were
initially saying we know the most about
this covet thing continue to say things
this outlandish listen to this they're
trying to change the very essence of our
DNA and there are people working on this
that's one of them you all know a Harare
which which is just not going to work
now by the way
just as a coincidence you've all know a
Harari who wrote sapiens and who wrote
homodeus and some other really great
books he just so happens to be Israeli
right he just so happens that he's
Jewish
um I know that they often criticize that
it's often true that the people they
pull into these conspiracy theories
aren't Jewish
but a whole heck of a lot of them are
and they mentioned Klaus Schwab and they
mentioned George Soros and now now
you've all know a Harari is the target
of it's these people are pathetic so
what do they do they're going to
basically put components of Robotics
into us well that's one of the other
issues that they are looking at so you
know everything from you you see the
robotic arms which can help somebody or
robotic lives which can help somebody
who lost their legs or somebody who lost
their movement of their arm or arm to be
able to do things and to live like a
normal life but those are that's
different than what these guys are
trying to do they're actually trying to
change inside the internals of something
that is unchangeable unmovable immovable
because they're designed by someone
other than them and thank God that God
designed us the way we are
you can't even possibly unpack that I
mean I'm not even going to try to unpack
the substance of it it's that is Bonker
stuff this is a guy who should be in a
psych ward or in prison now he you know
he was pardoned by Trump so
he was the National Security advisor of
the United States understand that
understand the the uh teetering over the
brink position that the United States
was in with guys like this and Trump
claimed he would hire the best people he
needs professional help and Trump put
him at the top position
for National Security in the country
this guy is leading anyone we have a
serious problem and now it is just a
word salad of DNA covid Yuval Harare
cyborg robotic components God designed
us scary stuff we should consider that
we dodged a bullet in a sense that Flynn
didn't last that long as National
Security advisor let me know what you
think find me on Twitter at D Pacman
I've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and I now protect myself with aura
Aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together Aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
Aura also does things like alert you if
they're a suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name I've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and I was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like Aura I highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com Pacman you
will get Aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below remember that the David
packman show is a audience and audience
I should say supported program primarily
through something called the membership
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code obamna beautiful code Obama
o-b-a-m-n-a to get a sizable discount
and of course you will get daily
commercial free streams audio and video
of the show much earlier than we release
them publicly every single day you'll
also get access to the bonus show an
extra show
every day for our members and we also
are doing the members only Town Halls
the most recent one was a couple weeks
ago I believe sign up at joinpakman.com
get that discount would love to welcome
you into the ranks of membership today
let's continue following up on the Ron
DeSantis Martha's Vineyard immigrant
stun one of the biggest I hesitate to
call it a confusion one of the biggest
misstatements that's being made about
the entire thing is that the 50 or
really 48 migrants who were flown to
Martha's Vineyard by Ron DeSantis on the
tax dollars of Floridians the claim is
being made that they are here illegally
when that is actually not the case and
the Casual nature with Republicans are
now claiming this is causing it to
spread like wildfire those migrants were
not here illegally I will explain that
in a moment here is Marco Rubio just one
example he was on Fox News yesterday or
maybe this was this morning uh this
morning in fact uh saying these are
folks who are are here illegally and of
course they were not well think about
this okay people came into this country
illegally violating our laws no okay and
the first thing they do is get lawyers
and use our laws to sue an elected
governor that's after they were lured
arguably illegally to get on a plane to
send them to Martha's Vineyard they are
only now suing and we will talk about
that lawsuit on the bonus show so a
state I mean just think about that they
just got here they're not even here
legally they didn't enter the country
the proper way and they're immediately
in court demanding rights and claims
under our laws this is outrageous what
other country in the world would that
even be allowed what other country in
the world would even tolerate that so I
think this is you know we have a this is
not immigration what we're seeing okay
this is mass migration that's a very
different thing and and but to think
about the fact that somebody just came
here illegally and within a week they're
in court and they have lawyers
representing them in court well that's
thanks to Ron DeSantis my friend suing
the American government who's lost they
just violated is is unbelievable it's
outrageous it angers me and it should
anger everybody so let's take this step
by step the picture painted but these
these Republicans lie constantly the
picture that Rubio is painting is a
bunch of illegal immigrants come to the
U.S they're here illegally and within
days they're using our court system to
sue others demanding rights and
demanding money that could not be
further from the truth first of all as
our friend Anna casparian tweeted quote
Asylum Seekers awaiting a decision from
immigration judges are not in the U.S
illegally also Cubans like Marco Rubio
who benefited from amnesty After the
revolution
Rubio's family to be clear should maybe
be more considerate and self-reflective
when weighing in on Venezuelan migrants
so when you think of the story that
Rubio tells illegal immigrants for no
reason using our courts to demand stuff
well first of all they're not illegal
immigrants when you are awaiting an
asylum decision you are here legally in
the sense that you are pending a legal
decision now Asylum is discretionary
meaning sometimes individuals
claim Asylum and it is denied to them
even if they technically meet the
definition of refugees this has to do
with the adjudication but when you do
the right thing you come to the Border
you request Asylum it is awaiting a
decision you are not here illegally so
the first piece of Rubio's story here
illegally
for no reason just filing lawsuits
actually not here illegally the second
part is the civil suit that has now been
filed by these migrants who are not here
illegally
has only been filed
because of what Ron DeSantis did
Ron DeSantis is now under criminal
investigation the State of Florida and
the DeSantis Administration under
criminal investigation for what is
tantamount to human trafficking they
lied and deceived these migrants lured
them to get on these planes saying
you're going to go to Boston and get
expedited legal status and jobs didn't
take him to Boston took him to Martha's
Vineyard and that is why there is now a
civil suit the story that Marco Rubio
and Republicans are telling doesn't have
any truth to it I mean it they're
mentioning that some of the migrants are
from Venezuela that's true right I mean
if we want to find something that is
accurate so they are lying and we should
be aware of that but unfortunately the
lies spread like wildfire it may or may
not surprise you
that the Texas Sheriff who is now
conducting a criminal investigation into
the Iran DeSantis Martha's Vineyard
migrant stunt which I told you about
yesterday is now receiving death threats
Vice has a very good article about this
by Paul blust Texas Sheriff getting
death threats after saying he'd
investigate DeSantis for migrant plane
stunt
this is the party of Law and Order
remember
the people who are issuing the death
threats so the way it went is as follows
Ron DeSantis had the bright idea to use
Florida taxpayer money to fly 48
migrants awaiting Asylum decisions from
Texas to Martha's Vineyard an island off
the coast of Massachusetts with a very
small population and limited resources
we learned after this took place that
the migrants were lied to they were
lured there with false promises of jobs
and other things this led to questions
as to whether this was even legal what
Ron DeSantis did or might qualify as
human trafficking we now have lawyers
who are representing the migrants who
have filed the civil suit we will talk
about that on the bonus show and we have
this Texas Sheriff named Javier Salazar
who is criminally investigating DeSantis
I told you about that yesterday
the Texas Sheriff said I'm going to
investigate this it seems that these
individuals were lured and that crimes
took place and now he has received and
his office have received quote numerous
threats on Tuesday a spokesperson told
Vice news there have been numerous
threats an influx of calls to our
dispatch and administrative offices
along with hateful emails received
additionally as in any instance when our
office receives threats precautionary
measures will be made for safety of all
personnel
these are the people who claim to be for
Law and Order they are cheering the
possibly illegal stun of luring migrants
to Martha's Vineyard but they claim to
be for Law and Order they are then
threatening the guy investigating the
possible criminality that took place it
is wild to see these Law and Order
people losing their minds
after calling themselves the party of
Law and Order for decades and saying
comply with law enforcement let them do
their work well that's what Sheriff
Salazar is trying to do and now they're
threatening his life and the life of
officers that work in his office and and
remember this is only over the
investigative process there hasn't even
been any indictment or charges and that
this is related to the Trump stuff as
well the magats are going bonkers merely
over the fact that Trump is being
investigated understand that the search
warrant execution is part of the
investigative phase we haven't gotten to
the indictment part we don't have any
charges yet and it remains to be seen
whether we will
even the investigation is enough to get
them to abandon the very Law and Order
that they cling to almost religiously
when it's a tool or a cudgel with which
they can attack the left and attack
Democrats what's important here to the
trumpist law enforcement officers and
the trumpist members of the military but
for the most part the law enforcement
officers
you should be aware that these Maga
people as much as they claim to support
you right now they will turn on you in
an instant if you don't support their
level of delusion 100
we saw it happen with the Capitol Police
oh back the blue Thin Blue Line support
law enforcement fund the police all
lives matter all this different stuff oh
wait all of a sudden the Capitol Police
were trying to stop the trumpists from
getting into the capital well write them
off we we mean support the police but
not those police
oh the FBI which is also uh law
enforcement
they did everything legally to execute a
search warrant at Donald Trump's home
well yeah I mean we back the blue but
not them I mean that's different they're
now they're they're becoming political
the principles don't matter they abandon
them whenever it is not convenient and
if you were in law enforcement they will
abandon you if you don't live up to
their delusional expectations we'll have
all the clips we played here on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
we're continuing our interviews with all
sorts of different 2022 candidates and
today I'm going to be speaking with Adam
Steen who's a self-described America
First candidate endorsed by the former
president Donald Trump currently running
a write-in campaign in the 63rd district
for the Wisconsin State Assembly Adam I
really appreciate your time today
thanks for having me David I appreciate
it so indulge me I know this we may get
through this first question in one word
and then we can move on but it's just a
good gut check who's the current
president of the United States
Donald Trump
oh the current president is Trump
no right right now it's Joe Biden sir
okay did he legitimately win do you
think does his presidency reflect the
will of the voters
uh I believe especially here in the
state of Wisconsin we have some major
questions that we'd like to ask and we
have not been able to bring those before
a judge here in the state of Wisconsin
who is preventing you from doing that
uh right now the only person that we can
find is uh my opponent Robin Voss he has
said multiple times that he is going to
do a full forensic cyber audit when he
got off the plane with the president
back August of last year and he has done
absolutely nothing of the sort in order
to find out really what people want to
know David they want to know that their
ballot counts their vote is actually
counted that's all they want to know and
what reason do we have right now to
question the results in which Joe Biden
won that state by 20 000 votes what
specifically do we have
uh in Wisconsin
so we have uh the Supreme Court
announcing their ruling uh back about a
month and a half ago that the ballot
drop boxes are and were illegal there's
two methods of delivering your ballot um
in the state of Wisconsin Constitution
by Statute you can deliver it in the
mail or you can deliver it in person to
the clerk
um the Wisconsin election commission
decided to add a third option which is a
ballot Dropbox which is not clearly
defined in the statute so when the
Supreme Court ruled they said those drop
boxes are and were illegal so there were
about 250 000 votes cast but Adam hold
on a second hold on I know I know you're
too too good to do this to us you know
that if you read that decision what they
found was that there were some locations
that were not accessible to individuals
with mobility issues and they did they
said nothing substantive about
fraud related to the final count or
anything of the sort no no no I
we knew the reason and you're exactly
right I would not mean to admit that
okay fair fair very correct David very
very correct the amount of ballots that
were cast by that method in lieu of the
fact that it doesn't follow the method
to deliver the ballot by the
Constitution yeah would in my case bring
to question the fact that those ballots
whether legal or not were cast in an
in-lawful manner you're exactly right
okay and do you also admit that while it
is totally within your right to
extrapolate whatever you want based on
that decision the justices who who wrote
the descending opinion say when people
say the types of things you're saying
you're Fanning political flames in a way
that is not good you're making people
think you're talking about fraudulent
results when all they said was some of
these weren't accessible to people with
disabilities that's all they said
so what what they said if you read the
the final decision is that they they're
the method of delivery is two sir right
so there's two methods of delivery in
the statute
yes so Wisconsin election commission
introduced a third without going through
this the legislature so that to me is an
extremely scary position to be in the
Supreme Court said that those those
boxes that were used were not under the
method of which delivery was described
in the Constitution so you are correct
I'm not trying to say that the Supreme
Court said the election's invalid none
of that good they just said they should
have all been accessible to individuals
with disabilities yep so yeah okay
the next thing that I'd like to point
out is we had justice gableman's 139
page report
and I would really like for that report
to be put before a judge and I would
like the judicial system to actually
make a ruling on the findings of that
report okay so the Wisconsin election
commission decided to remove special
voting deputies right
they said they were not necessary in
2020
and I believe from my bottom of my heart
my great-grandmother died at 102 at our
house that they were
that they were removed and we had people
that were executing the elections and
collecting ballots that were not under
the Constitution they were not followed
okay so you've re you've raised a couple
of concerns that's that's fair and but
you're also conceding that uh on that
first one it's really about disability
rights let me ask you this what is a
forensic election audit because and the
reason I ask is everybody I ask has a
different explanation and when I point
to audits that have that have been done
folks will invariably say that's not
really the type of audit I'm talking
about
um got it that's a very fair question
because you're exactly right David let's
go across the country right you look at
Arizona yeah and look at Georgia even
here in Wisconsin the the audit that
that we'd like to find out is what what
happens to your ballot when it goes
through the machine I'm not telling you
the machines are fraudulent I can't tell
you that David you can't tell me that
okay I certainly can't tell you the
machines are fraudulent because I have
no reason to believe that yeah
and and I can't either right so good can
I can I maybe reframe this discussion a
little bit so you can reframe it but I
would love an answer to what you mean by
a forensic election I apologize so a
friends that got it is when when your
ballot gets cast right yes the process
by which your ballot is cast once that
ballot goes into whether it's scanned
through a machine goes into a box in a
County Courthouse gets counted yes and
the total results are finished I believe
that process should be clear to the
public so a friends that got it to me is
understanding every step of that process
without equivocation okay now let me see
if I understand it and you tell me the
elements that are missing right because
I voted with these types of machines
before
um I have a ballot there's two options I
have a ballot I take my felt Sharpie and
I sort of like connect two little black
things and make it a a fixed line I feed
it in through a machine presumably the
machine identifies which line I drew and
credits that candidate with a vote and
then my ballot goes into a pile and then
later you could go back in and count up
the pieces of paper with the lines and
compare it to the results from the
machine is that a fair process
that that process yeah is part of the
audit program okay you're exactly right
yes okay and what else is there
well for for me in Wisconsin we we have
a process called early absentee voting
okay
and that's 47 days that starts September
22nd for the general election yep
in my opinion
based on the the I'd say the evidence if
you will that has never been presented
before court that we have men and women
here in Wisconsin there's a there's a
case yesterday that they heard the doj
brought against a man by the name of
Harry Waite
Airy weight it's requested a ballot an
absentee ballot for five people
with their birth date and their first
and last name that's the only thing you
need to request their ballot if they
voted absentee in the past there's no ID
required
because they've already submitted a
request for an absentee ballot
the problem that I have is let's say
that what you and I just described is
perfectly Flawless yeah right I'll
concede to that let's say it's perfectly
flawless
if you and I would like to request
ballots from an individual who has voted
one out of the last 15 election cycles
and we submit it being an absentee
ballot in a mailbox sure
there is no way for you and I
based on the process You just defined
to confirm or deny whether or not that
ballot was cast by that individual so a
few things on that because I've heard
and read about this many many times
before there's a few different things
number one is
even if what what you're saying is true
in theory someone could do that I could
find someone who hasn't voted in a
really long time I'm admitting you're
right I could I could try to figure out
who hasn't voted in a really long time
request a ballot in their name and then
fill it out and send it in fine in order
for us to be able to say it's worth
X Y or Z audit investigation whatever I
would want to number one have evidence
that that happened in numbers that could
have swayed the results and in order to
believe that I would have to have reason
to think that one side rather than the
other was disproportionately doing it
because even if I grant that what you're
saying could be done and was done
if it was done equally by Republicans
and Democrats it doesn't actually change
the outcome does it does my math check
out at least Adam in other words if ten
thousand Republicans do that and ten
thousand Democrats do that with these
people who haven't voted in a while
Biden still wins by Twenty Thousand
votes right the math checks out at least
oh
and is he was that question too tough I
can't believe that was why he left Adam
where are you
oh my I
I think he bailed because of that
question
what on Earth
Adam don't tell me that question was too
difficult
Adam you're back
we were on hold yeah you put I thought
you bailed because that you didn't like
the question
no sir okay so my question was I'm glad
you're back my question was if 10 000
Democrats and 10 000 Republicans do the
thing you described it doesn't change
the margin of Victory so the question I
have is what evidence do we have that
what you just described as possible was
not only done but was done by so many
more Democrats than Republicans that it
would change the outcome in Wisconsin
I I would like to contend that your your
premise of your question is wrong okay I
won't argue with your question tell me
how it's wrong
well so
um my grandfather was an 82nd Airborne
Division we have men and women who have
died for this country so that we can
have the right to vote Yes I I
personally believe that if if you use
the line of questioning that you've so
chosen that if both sides do it it's
okay that's not the that's not what I
said though
okay so it's a two-part question first
go ahead what evidence do we have that
this was done in large numbers at all
because that's been investigated in
Wisconsin and part two is if it was done
in large numbers was it done
disproportionately by one side
so I would love absolutely love to hear
uh first of all the premise of the
investigation that happened because this
is the perfect crime David okay you'd
say that uh someone voted absentee and
their ballot was determined that they
actually did vote absentee and it was
found that they really didn't vote
because that would make it canvas when I
say a full friends that got it that
would take a canvas of the people that
actually were elected or voted in this
election so you're saying go door
knocking all the people who supposedly
voted and say did you really vote well
no no I'm asking your question you you
said that that was uh investigated
please tell me how was that investigated
because that's the only method I know to
verify what you just said well you do it
with a sample it was invet you I mean so
again if the standard is you want to
look up every absentee vote and then go
and check with the person did you vote
it could be done
it would require an insane amount of
resources in when we when we talk about
science when we talk about mathematical
significance you can take a sample of
those and investigate them and when we
do that when we take a representative
sample we find uh a combination of
things you know usually a few people who
were alive when they sent in their
absentee ballot and died by election day
they didn't do anything wrong sometimes
people die you find examples of like
junior senior confusion where that yes a
junior voted as their dead father but
the dead father didn't vote so it
doesn't it's still just one vote it was
just counted for the wrong you you get
to this point where there's really
nothing there when you test a
representative sample so again for me to
say let's check everyone I would want to
have a sample that raises concerns and
that that hasn't happened when it's been
looked at in Wisconsin
so so just to be clear
um I I did not know and you're you're
telling me that we did actually sample a
county because we did canvassing here in
Wisconsin in Racine County yeah and we
found 400 people voting
from a single family household okay in
the 2020 election so if if you have
different evidence let's talk about that
but right right now I I would love love
to do some digging but I'm not going to
sit and argue with the fair fair okay I
think I've raised enough questions for
you to understand the origins of my
skepticism and you've pointed out what
you want so I think we can we can move
on but you have questions that you don't
feel have been answered just just one
more thing sir seriously with with
regards to our election
um to me the issue is really
can be solved in eight words it's simple
I I would like our election process to
be done in person on paper and count one
day and that would apply to Donald Trump
as well right because he voted earlier
months early by mail he wouldn't be able
to do that
every person except the military and our
elderly that are unable to get out and
vote because to me the men and women of
this country that have given their lives
so that you and I can have the freedom
to even have this conversation right
vote they died and gave their life so
that we could take the responsibility
that we have to make sure we go vote in
my election process right in just my
little District yep less than 10 voted
in the primary yeah that's depressing
and that's common and sadly low voter
engagement I want more voter engagement
it is but but I guess to me the solution
is I would like transparency a lot of
the questions that you and I are
discussing our system has been set up so
that you and I can't come to a
conclusion we can't come to a realistic
idea that we know that our vote was
counted and cast clearly and no one was
Adam listen I I gotta I want to get some
some other topics one of the things I
found super interesting was at one point
you wrote you would outlaw
contraceptives if you were given that
opportunity do I have that right and why
would you do that
well conveniently enough uh you you
don't have it correct okay the New York
Post I believe it was
um was that where the this I don't have
the source in front of me I read a bunch
of stuff before I interviewed him yeah I
I did not write that
um they asked me what I believed
personally yeah
and I said very clearly that I believe
that life begins a conception your body
is your choice and you make a decision
before conception happens okay you and I
are in adults we know how children are
come to this world
and if you make a choice there's a
consequence for that choice I personally
believe that stopping the natural
progression of Life which you again made
a decision
in order to engage in sexual activity
as a person as an individual
that is something that I believe is
wrong to stop Life as a as a
representative I'm not going to put the
lid back on Pandora's Box okay so you
wouldn't move to ban contraception but
you're against it you in other words you
believe even a condom is stopping the
process of life
personally yeah I'm talking about you
personally I know it's just you
personally
well there's a difference between policy
and personally yeah so so personally yes
I believe that you are actually just
making a decision to engage in an
activity and you want to remove the
consequence and this applies not just to
uh oral contraceptives and plan B but
you're saying even a condom is
interfering with is it is it God's will
that you find is it religiously based or
where are you coming up with this uh no
I I'm saying you're trying to remove the
consequence for your decision you want
to enjoy an activity that you have a
physical pleasure yeah and you will
remove into consequence that is wouldn't
that apply also to for example wearing a
seat belt in a car where the natural
consequence of driving fast might be
that you get hurt in an accident and the
seat belt is artificially keeping you uh
safe I mean it's sort of a weird
argument isn't it
it's a weird argument safe uh safety and
saving a life versus ending a life to me
is a an interesting but you consider
wearing a condom to be ending a life
well you're preventing a life right so
why it's it's deferring a consequence
that's what I'm saying wow that's
interesting that's right I've never I've
honestly I've heard right Wingers say
Insurance shouldn't cover some of these
things but I've never heard anyone say
that condoms are just straight up wrong
that's so you're saying that view it's
not based on your religious beliefs
no I I believe that like David if think
about life if life doesn't begin a
conception if you don't defend life at
all stages yeah whether it be or end
what what part at what point does life
have value well if you're using a condom
there's been no conception right you're
going even earlier
what happens at the end of life sir if
you're telling me that we'd like to have
um no consequences for any decision that
you make that's what you're telling me
that we would like to have plan B well I
decided to have sex right that's that's
how that's how conception happens I
would like to defer that consequence I'm
not going to say that government's going
to legislate morality they can't okay
then as a legislator wow that this is
mind-blowing Adam I've never heard this
from anyone I mean you may be in some
way the most uh socially conservative
person no condoms that and and you so
how old were you when you came to this
view this anti-condom View
foreign
makes it kind of sound funny well it is
very funny I think I mean it's it's very
you're saying we have to defend all life
and like are you is masturbation wrong
can I ask that
is masturbation wrong right because then
you're talking about millions of
potential lives that are no never going
to get a chance
as as an individual yeah all is an
individual
well I I have been taught and I have
come to the conclusion in my life yeah
that I I believe that you are enjoying
um an activity that's there's nothing
wrong with it but at the end of the day
you you are actually like you said you
are snuffing out life but I have not
done
probation is is illegal sir wow
Adam we are treading incredible new
ground here I have to say this is good
this is going to be I can't think of a
more interesting note on which we would
end than that
um but this is really giving me a lot of
uh a lot to think about I think for lack
of a better term
um the election is in November Adam
Steen is running to represent District
63 in the Wisconsin State Assembly he
has been endorsed by Donald Trump we
don't know whether Donald Trump is on
the same page on some of the condom
stuff I think it would be interesting to
to talk to him about that but Adam I
appreciate so much your time today and
you laying out some of your views
thanks David I appreciate it
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well
Donald Trump's own special Master is
kind of telling him to cut the crap this
is not going particularly well for the
failed former president so far and it's
super interesting because this is
exactly what Donald Trump wanted so let
me reset the story so we all get on the
same page one of the things or really
the main thing that Donald Trump and his
lawyers did to try to slow down this
investigation by the FBI that happened
subsequent to the search warrant being
executed at Mar-A-Lago where all of
these documents were taken what Donald
Trump did is demand the appointment of a
special Master special Master would get
to take control of the documents seized
by the FBI and review them and say do
some of these have private medical
information are some of these privileged
in some way and slow down the FBI's
ability to use those documents in their
investigation Trump hand-picked a
special master and the special Master is
doing Donald Trump no favors and it's
actually a delight U.S this is from
talking points memo U.S District Judge
Raymond Deary for the eastern district
of New York injected some normalcy into
Trump's civil case against the justice
department Deary chastised attorneys for
Trump during the hearing for refusing to
produce any evidence that the record
seized by the FBI from Mar-A-Lago in
August had actually been Declassified
Jim trust the a trump attorney told
Deary he wanted to examine the records
taken by the government as he decided
whether to make that assertion and Deary
said you can't have your cake and eat it
too Deary exhibited skepticism of the
Trump team's classification arguments
elsewhere in the hearing he kept asking
Trump's team versions of the same
question if I'm going to verify the
classification what am I looking for
um this is really really interesting
here is a report from CNN about what
went down judge Deary posed a question
to Trump's teamwork he said to them you
know if he gets a prima facie case that
the documents are classified perhaps by
the markings and if Trump's teams don't
tell him that these documents were
Declassified he said he essentially
would as far as he could as he is
concerned he would go with the Prima
facia case and that would be the end of
it right so really putting the issue to
Trump's lawyers he noted that the burden
was on them in this case for them to
decide if they were going to put forward
any position that any of these documents
had been Declassified and as we've been
talking that is something that the
former president has said publicly on
his social media feed but it is not in
argument that his attorneys have made
yet in this case this is the best and
I've talked to you about this before one
of I did a clip must have been about two
weeks ago where I said are Trump's
lawyers going to try these arguments in
court and one of the arguments was about
the classification status of some of the
seized documents in and Trump's alleged
broad blanket Abracadabra
declassification and one of the things
we've learned is that a lot of the
things you say in the media don't hold
up in court we saw this after the 2020
election in the 60 plus cases that were
brought to different courts in this
particular case
in social media and elsewhere the
argument has been made Trump
Declassified everything and what the
special Master is saying is if you hand
me a document and it says classified and
you don't assert and prove that Trump
Declassified it
that's it it's a classified document and
that's all there is to it and this is
not what the Trump team was hoping for
really funny as Trump's legal team is
showing up to court there's someone
holding a nuclear secret sign in the
background and people yelling indict
Trump and all sorts of other hilarious
things
[Music]
hahaha
all right so a brief moment of
excitement there outside the courthouse
I've said it before try it in court try
it under oath and then they don't so
we're going to be following this very
closely but early on this entire special
Master thing not going particularly well
for Donald Trump I want speaking of
court cases not going particularly well
I have a very interesting video of
Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
in Connecticut this is the latest Alex
Jones defamation trial remember I
interviewed the plaintiff's attorney
Mark Bankston not long ago and he told
us about this forthcoming case this is
absolutely fantastic Alex Jones flipped
out outside the courthouse yesterday
saying the judge isn't allowing me to
argue that I'm innocent
now that's not the way Court works and
I'm going to tell you why in a second
but take a listen to what Alex Jones had
to say
before Nana or South Africa this is
serious tyranny regardless what you
think about me or how the media is
playing over the years I've apologized
for past things I said to hurt people's
feelings but I wasn't the first person
to question Sandy Hook and I apologize
years ago they have misrepresented what
I've said and done there's a whole
industry of lawyers around these
families of Sue Remington and won 73
million dollars and won all these other
lawsuits and they simply now are not
just coming for the Second Amendment but
the First Amendment travesty of justice
and this judge is a tyrant this judge is
ordering me to say that I'm guilty and
to say that I'm a liar none of that's
true I was not wrong about Sandy Hook on
purpose I questioned it Just Like Jesse
smallin just like wmd's in Iraq just
like Gulf of Tonkin there have been a
lot of staged events
in history like wmd's in Iraq and I
question every major event that we see
and so I'm being put in an impossible
position inside of this Courthouse where
I'm being ordered to say I'm guilty has
anybody ever heard of someone being
ordered to say they're guilty okay so
Alex Jones of course is not telling the
truth here's what's going on in this
case
a default judgment was already ordered
last year against Alex Jones because he
refused to participate in Discovery
there was a defamation suit brought Alex
Jones was ordered to participate in
Discovery what that means is you have to
turn over information you have to turn
over documents evidence Etc
if you don't do it it's
similar to just not showing up to court
okay when you don't do it a default
judgment is found against you you lose
by default it's sort of like you forfeit
and that's what took place we are now in
the damages phase and Jones is trying to
argue his innocence that is not for this
phase that is supposed to be done in the
phase which he forfeited the right to
participate in because he didn't
participate in Discovery so he's saying
it's like communist China it's like this
it's like that it's a t the judge is a
tyrant
these are the rules he didn't
participate in Discovery this was the
case in the other defamation suit as
well and now we are in the damages phase
that's how the law works and he claims
to be about Law and Order and uh how
very quickly that idea evaporates but
just absolutely pathetic this is going
to be another fascinating trial we have
a voicemail number you can call in any
time that number is 2192 David P this is
a really good voicemail John fetterman
the Democratic Senate candidate in
Pennsylvania running against television
Dr Mehmet Oz had a stroke not too long
ago and he has been recovering from that
stroke many right Wingers are now saying
fetterman is not cognitively there and
so this caller says hey you know Trump
brags about passing that Montreal
cognitive assessment what if fetterman
took it would that satisfy Republicans
uh hi David I'm calling from Australia
just um why doesn't fetterman just take
that Montreal cognitive assessment test
yeah I'd love to see the Republicans
tell them that's not very serious excuse
me love the show yeah
obviously the very Republicans who say
the Montreal cognitive assessment proves
Trump's a genius or whatever they said
if fetterman took and passed the
Montreal cognitive assessment as he
certainly would they would not be
satisfied it's a double standard we all
know that the Montreal cognitive
assessment is meant to screen for
relatively serious dementia
and when Donald Trump bragged and then
Sean Hannity bragged about Trump passing
the test
we all knew it didn't really mean
anything
but they claim it's proof that Trump is
brilliant if fetterman passed it they
would come up with a completely
different standard so I think it would
be great if he did it I think it would
be amazing trolling to say I got a
perfect score on the Montreal cognitive
assessment I did as well as Trump did
the Republicans claiming fetterman is
cognitively disabled are not going to be
satisfied on today's bonus show we are
going to talk about the civil lawsuit
filed by the Martha's Vineyard migrants
against Ron DeSantis it is a fascinating
turn of events as a criminal
investigation has also started into
DeSantis we are also going to talk about
the scheme to steal 250 million dollars
from the pandemic child food program
disgusting people truly Joe Biden has
also endorsed a bill to disclose Super
PAC donors that's a good idea but what's
actually in the bill
and lastly the Pacman Finance channel
has launched the first video clip is up
I would love for you to subscribe at
youtube.com
pacmanfinance and we'll tell you about
the plan for that channel and the behind
the scenes very soon on the bonus show
get access to the bonus show by signing
up at joinpakman.com oh the bonus show
where you want to
money to fund themselves as bad thank
you very much Alex for that endorsement
you can sign up at joinpakman.com you
can use the coupon code bigdeal919
big deal 919 to get a discount and we
will see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors I protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
Aura I get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so I can fix the problem
fast try Aura free for two weeks using
my link below